on November 14th 2017 Zimbabwe military
troops drove tanks into the capital city
Herrara
[Music]
they patrol the streets blocked access
to government buildings and took over
the state television station to insist
that this is not a military takeover of
God but it clearly was troops invaded
the presidential palace and put the
President Robert Mugabe in custody
Kwami regime and his family are safe and
sound and their security is guaranteed
when you hear that a military coup has
happened it's common to assume that the
result is a transfer of power but in
this case it's very clear there is no
revolution it's merely an internal fight
among the country's elites Zimbabwe is
one of the most corrupt countries in the
world and what we're seeing is a fight
to keep it that way as soon as we have
accomplished our mission we expect that
the situation would attend once praised
as a war hero Robert Mugabe helped
Zimbabwe win independence from Great
Britain in 1980 he became president
under Zimbabwe new constitution with the
wide support of the people
but soon he digress into a repressive
dictator he secured his power through
aggression and threats and there have
been reports of state-sponsored torture
and killings
now that Mugabe is 93 years old and
reportedly in poor health the fight for
political influence is more intense than
ever and it's caused a split in Mugabe
his own party the zanu-pf
on one side we have the old guard led by
Mugabi sacked vice president Emerson and
GOG WA light Mugabe he fought for
Zimbabwe's independence and has a
checkered past that includes human
rights abuses against political
opponents and ethnic minorities as an
old friend of Mugabe and vice-president
since 2014 GOG WA was the heir apparent
for many years but all that changed on
November 6th
when Mugabe 's government said Managua
had exhibited traits of disloyalty and
fired him it seems to indicate Mugabe
support for another successor Grace
Mugabe his own wife she has recently
risen within the party but is extremely
unpopular nationwide mostly due to
expensive shopping habits which earned
her the nickname Gucci grace
the military has sided with among Gaga
that when it comes to methods of
protecting our revolution the military
will not hesitate stepping on November
15th that did just that taking control
of the capital and what they deemed a
guardian coup protecting the Zimbabwe
people and democracy but their interests
are more self-motivated they want to
secure their own power they have control
over lucrative farming and mining
operations and access to foreign
currency to keep this power they need a
united zanu-pf who face elections
scheduled in 2018 so what's missing in
all of this the people of Zimbabwe
whoever ends up in charge GOG wa the
military or Grace Mugabe corruption will
continue all these actors want to keep
the status quo but for the general
population the status quos a society of
unequal opportunity during Mugabe is 37
years of leadership massive corruption
was commonplace there have been repeated
allegations of Mugabe and his cabinet
embezzling money from mining and diamond
industries Mugabe even won the
state-owned lottery in 2000 transparency
international estimates that Zimbabwe
loses a billion dollars a year to
corruption
all the while Zimbabwe's economy has
suffered the poverty rate is at 72%
inflation have reached peaks of 231
million percent and GDP growth has been
stagnant this is made Zimbabwe one of
the most economically unequal countries
in the world a problem that shares with
much of the region
studies show that low levels of economic
growth and high levels of poverty are
common conditions in African countries
that experienced military cooze in fact
36% of all coup attempts since 1950 have
occurred in Africa the problem is that
coos rarely addressed these problems
military coos in ejr Burkina Faso and
Burundi were attempts by leaders to
extend their term limits while coos in
Guinea and Togo were sparked by
competition over secession the same
appears to be happening in Zimbabwe
what's uncertain in the near future is
in bob ways political leadership what's
certain is that politicians fight over
their own self-interests and those of
the people are forgotten
[Music]